avant de lancer son offensive contre
l'ukraine vladimir poutine avait un
objectif en tête l'invasion devaient
être conclus en quelques jours un
scénario loin d'être atteint 3 mois
après la russie a progressé dans le sud
et l'est notamment dans les zones
séparatistes du dombass mais la
tentative d'envahir la capitale kiev a
été contrecarré au bout d'un mois les
opérations pour prendre aux dessins ont
été repoussés et à kharkiv deuxième
ville du pays les forces russes ont dû
repartir selon les services de
renseignement occidentaux plus de
soldats russes ont été tués en trois
mois en ukraine que pendant les neuf
années de la guerre en afghanistan
environ quinze mille soldats russes ont
été tués au cours de leur offensive en
plus du nombre de morts ou des dommages
matériels plusieurs sources suggèrent
qu'à ce jour plus de 2000 véhicules
blindés ont été détruits ou capturés
l'ampleur de l'échec inattendu peut
s'expliquer par la résilience de l'armée
ukrainienne une arme et réorganiser et
modernisé suite à l'annexion de la
crimée par la russie en 2014 elle a pu
profiter de l'aide militaire envoyé par
l'occident comme des missiles américains
l'armée russe elle s'est révélée
beaucoup moins performante que prévu
manque d'autonomie décisionnel
incapacité à coordonner les forces
aériennes et terrestres mais aussi
défaut de l'artillerie moscou se vante
de la mise en service de nouvelles armes
censées être surpuissante le 18 mai
volodymyr zelensky se moque d'un nouveau
laser
nous voyons qu'au 3ème mois d'une guerre
totale la russie essaie de trouver son
arme miracle
maintenant c'est un laser
ou cela montre clairement l'échec
complet de la mission
les échecs de la russie sur le terrain
l'ont conduite à se concentrer sur les
bombardements de longue portée dévastant
des villes ciblées comme mario paul
mais malgré ces revers le conflit est
loin d'être terminé
les analystes militaires prévoient une
guerre d'usure dans l'est du pays